good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday that feels
like a Monday but it also feels like a
like a Thursday I don't know it's
feeling crazy I'm so out of sorts yeah I
can't keep track of what day it is and
what day it isn't
um and this week just kind of needs to
cycle through itself and we can start
again on a fresh foot though I'm not
trying to like Rush away the three-day
weekend I am feeling utterly confused
I'm feeling utterly confused utterly
grateful you know I'm never gonna I'm
Never Gonna Knock
knock a long weekend because
because it's great but I think I'd be
remiss devastated and heartbroken if I
didn't acknowledge this weird sort of
limbo feeling I'm feeling I think a lot
of people are feeling it I'm seeing
people who like were posting last night
being like Sunday feels and then they're
like Oh wait [__] it's not Sunday no and
I'm relating to them and I definitely
feel like you know I'm at a point in my
life where I've really evolved past like
the Sunday scaries like I feel good on
Sundays like I always reset I clean I
wash my hair like I've I turned it
around I've made Sundays my [__] a
little bit so I haven't had that feeling
in a while but like yesterday it was
like so negative it was so toxic
actually damn and that was the holiday
itself I know I was thinking that I'm
like not me and Jackie praising July 4th
being on a Tuesday and look at low-key
sucks it kind of wasn't all it was
cracked up to me I mean I can't really
speak because I didn't have like a
proper July 4th weekend we were just in
the city and doing like activities
um in the neighborhood so we didn't like
have the long weekend and you know we
weren't grilling up even though I did
have some watermelon yesterday which was
incredibly festive that's so July 4th it
was so July 4th and it was so tasty
um
but I just felt like the weekend never
started and it never ended no I love
that description like it was weird yeah
and everybody kind of had like different
work schedules so some people like they
only had Tuesday other people are like
Thursday night where's the party at and
it's like we need to get on the same
page as a country no because we were not
United at all this week and you could
totally feel it and July 4th is a
holiday about Unity yeah and we were
just kind of all over the place
disjointed as a country yeah I hate to
be better America I hate to complain
about days off because you know we had
days off and we should just like
celebrate but I'd be you know we gotta
be honest it wasn't like you know like
it wasn't no it wasn't but now I'm
grateful that next year is the leap year
and July 4th will be on a Thursday next
year which makes it extremely clear
where and when we're celebrating and
then it's like the holiday is the
Thursday so we like have the big holiday
and then it's Friday and one's going to
work that Friday and then it's like you
go straight into the weekend I think
this whole experiment has taught us the
ideal day for July 4th is a Thursday not
a Wednesday like we thought also there's
the days of the week but then also the
dates like the fact that July 4th
weekend started on June 30th and it was
like never July 4th it kept being July
2nd and we're celebrating July 4th like
next year July 4th will be the first day
of the weekend and then we come back to
work it's July 8th hey we're a quarter
of the way through July I'm already
looking forward to next year like let's
plan something oh we're for sure
planning something because I didn't get
my proper July 4th though I did get to
see fireworks last night because that
was July 4th bed rest Edition
um not as good as July 4th q and up
Edition pool party edition q and up
barbecue
oh queuing up I thought you were like
okay I'm sorry continue yeah not as good
as July 4th pickleball Edition yeah but
we had our fun
you always do yeah streis was love and
life
you had some good times snitch actually
came over for the fourth that's lovely
yeah we had a reading play date we both
finished our redheads book because we're
recording the new episode tonight this
book was so good and I learned so much
it's above us it like it just took me
into like a whole new community like
it's about
um a boarding school for Deaf kids and
it's just about like Deaf culture and
throughout the book there's like sign
language interspersed so I've been
practicing some sign language hey look
at you I can spell Bruno
of course you can and I could I'm
working on Jackie but it's it doesn't
roll off the fingers as nicely as Bruno
no because Bruno's perfect and that
makes sense yeah so that's I learned so
much I'm really excited to record and
the episode comes out tomorrow
big day big day we haven't had a
redheads episode in like six weeks due
to this shifting calendar
today's episode is my favorite type of
episode because you and I haven't seen
each other in like five days I know it's
been hard we also haven't really chatted
because you've been like lit you know
and we don't FaceTime when you're so lit
unless you have a question for me yeah
which I did
um
and we just have so much catching up to
do of course Kyle and Mauricio there's
so much to discuss in the news which is
great so much so that Jackie and I have
actually decided today so we're not
rushed or anything we're gonna move to
your toasters to tomorrow I had the
submissions and they're really good and
I want to be able to like fully engage
and not you know be an hour and a half
in and be like I know it's time to feed
your toes yeah and I want to give it my
all and also tomorrow we'll be in studio
and dear toasters is always fun together
and it will be fun to do it tomorrow so
I hope that's okay plus the days of the
week don't really apply this week so I
don't feel like we're beholding to
Wednesday dear toasters considering it's
not a Wednesday it's literal lawlessness
like we don't have to follow any rules
no and also we make the rules
I get what I want and this winter break
I want Jordan we make the rules and we
break the rules we make the rules
yeah
yeah I couldn't I couldn't think of like
another rebuttal that was better than
yours no but you just like have to have
the last
person what's it called the last word
yeah no like that's me
fine yeah whatever it's success I was
actually thinking this morning I was
like oh I need to recap my weekend on
the toast my weekend started like a
month ago I totally forgot like we
podcasted Friday right
we did remote
remote and then Friday night look
literally I took this like this feels
like a month ago me and Ben saw Ricky
Gervais like that doesn't even feel
even remotely recent but it was amazing
I wanted to tell everyone like you gotta
see Ricky if he's in your town we
weren't even planning it Ben was just
like looking up like things and going on
in the city and we're like oh should we
go to like maybe see Ricky Gervais and
we literally about like got tickets like
maybe two hours before it was incredible
oh my God he's so [__] funny and he's
so out of pocket like you just can't
believe the [__] that comes out of his
mouth and what I really appreciated was
so we did this whole show it was
hysterical I don't want to like the
whole weekend me and Ben were like
telling people we saw Ricky Gervais like
we each had favorite parts and we were
trying to like tell people what Ricky
said and we were just botchy and like
honestly making Ricky look so bad you
there's nobody should really ever try
and like
reenact like something you saw on a
stand-up like you just really it's one
of those things you had to be there for
that didn't stop us from like literally
retelling all these jokes and everyone
was like oh so funny you know I'm like
but it really was so funny but what I
really liked about Ricky's show I'd
never seen Ricky Gervais live and I'm
not even a particular like big Ricky
girl you know
um so I didn't know that this was a
thing he did but everyone around me
seemed to like know because when it was
over he like bowed and waved and nobody
got up I'm like move I'm like I gotta
beat the rush I gotta go and nobody
moved I'm like what and he comes back
out so he has this obviously like very
um
what's the word provocative Persona like
he says crazy [__] and he makes jokes
and he goes there and I feel like he
wants to make it clear like that's not
who he is he just like likes to make
jokes like that because it's [__]
funny so he does his set where he's just
saying that you know crazy [__] and then
he comes back out and just gives like a
three minute not even a performance he
just talks to the audience like as Ricky
you know he comes out Ricky he does the
Ricky Gervais show and then he comes out
as Ricky and he just like talks about
like the state of the world and we just
wishes everyone could get along like it
was actually I really liked him in
middle school right I really liked that
thing like I've never seen anyone do
that and it really you know you got to
know the man behind behind the show damn
that's beautiful turdy Lou I highly
recommend it's called like the
Armageddon tour I mean he talks about
like all the backlash she got on his
last comedy special I'm sure he's gonna
film this one for Netflix he's really so
funny I mean Ben this is much more like
Ben's type of humor I swear to God I
never been never left so hard at
anything I've ever said like killing
Jackie his head was resting on the chair
in front of him he like couldn't breathe
I'm like oh my God okay calm down and
like it was funny I'm like calm down
though that's so funny you told me I
should go the next night I thought about
it it just was a little too ambitious
for me but I wish I could have gone no
I'm like Ben you literally live with a
comedian like
calm down he acts like he's never like
heard a joke before no and then he's on
Instagram and then he's on Instagram
being like if you can see Ricky Gervais
it is the best comedy in the I'm like
you literally are so [__] rude like
you're so rude yeah that is rude yeah
like that would be like you promoting
a different can cocktail no like just
going out for drinks and being like Oh
my God this canned wine is the most
delicious thing I've ever seen like how
have I never had this before everybody
needs to get this I have a chance to
drink this yes you have to go go do like
so [__] hurtful that's funny
um but it was like a great way to kick
off the weekend
and I stayed in the city
see like we had like two weekends
because I stayed in the city till Sunday
yeah but you you went to a party on the
sun on Saturday on Saturday so Ricky
Friday I went out to Long Island to hit
up the annual Kyle and Kristen use check
Fourth of July party my first year being
invited I keep saying annual like I go
every year it's annual for them yeah not
for me for you I don't know the way I
behaved if I'll be invited by
but it was so fun I love like a house
party and they live on the water and it
was just so fun like you know I'm kind
of like a member of the 49ers family I
think I think I would say I think a lot
of people would say that you know I'm
just kind of like a 40 I'm kind of a
staple in the in the San Francisco 49ers
Community I'd say you're a family friend
no I would say I'm a family member oh
okay okay sure
no you wouldn't say that I would say
you're a family friend because the
family like they actually they committed
their whole lives to their kid playing
football and like all of the ups and
downs and like will they get drafted
like you didn't go through any of that
like you're here for the ride you're a
family friend no I think I went through
some of that okay
um it was so fun oh my God it was just
like you know fratty energy like beer
pong
frat Queen I do you know who taught me
that you it's so true she got her taste
for it when she would come visit me yeah
like I went to NYU I wasn't doing you
know like keg stands anywhere I was
literally like sitting in my room crying
um
so whenever I would go visit Jackie I
would like get to experience like real
college things you had like frats and we
would do keg stands and like
whatever and so funny actually I forgot
to tell you this so Kyle use check which
like is such an interesting fact about
him he went to Harvard for football and
I guess there's like this thing that
started at Harvard it's called the
dunkaroo where you basically like if you
saw it on my Instagram I posted it on
Tick Tock you have to like somebody
holds up your legs kind of like a keg
stand but it's over a big bucket of ice
cold water and you have to dip your head
in for 10 seconds and then chug a beer
when you get out and everyone was doing
it it's all right so they said it was a
Rite of Passage to become a member of
the 49ers family that's what they said
oh so that's how you're a family member
now yeah and so I did it and it was so
[__] fun I felt like a real Harvard
grad and then I posted it on Instagram
and I was like I broke my I didn't say I
said my first time like doing a dunkaroo
or whatever and your college friend Sam
was like Claudia you've literally done
one like with me like you were there
I don't even remember you doing dunking
your head I remember I did a keg stand
me too me too I did a keg stand that was
the first time at when I visited you at
college but she was like I literally
have a picture of you and Jackie like
you were doing it like we've done it I
didn't do it she said she could not get
me to wet my hair in college that's true
that's true I let alone in the middle of
a party the plot thickens well she's a
picture I want to see it yeah I said
like I said find the picture and she was
like you know like maybe I was holding
your legs being a supportive sis but no
actually if she did she gets when what
year what party maybe I could place it I
don't know if she's telling the truth or
not if she's like remembering correctly
she's pretty truthful and accurate as a
historian well I'm just gonna choose to
believe like my first time doing a
dunkaroo was like with George Kittle and
Kyle you check like that's the story I'm
telling my grandchildren okay that's
fine but also we could kind of split it
and be like this was turdy's first time
doing it on Guru true and back then you
were just Claudia yeah
so boring so ugly so many moles so this
was turdy lose first on grew and that's
factual and then I became like kind of
hooked on the way I felt afterwards like
the ice was freezing but you know it's
like kind of the cold plunge theater
that's what I was gonna say it's like
the Wim Hof thing Jackie you would have
thought like I took ecstasy I was like
it feels amazing like I felt so and it
wasn't even like particularly hot like I
became obsessed with just the feeling of
like dunking my face in like ice cold
water and I I totally understand like
the science like people love cold
plunging and like I kind of experienced
like a small taste of that and I loved
it I was doing it all weekend like we
kept feeling it was really hot this
weekend when I went to Brian's house we
kept filling up like these coolers with
ice and water and just sticking our
heads in it and it felt so good so are
you gonna go to Home Depot and get a
cold plunge bath no I don't know maybe
it's like added to the list of things
shorty had said she would never do and
now she is an advocate for but you do
remember when we cold plunged right yes
we cold plunged in the ocean the
Atlantic and literally of October and I
remember being like this is the best
feeling like when we got out it was so
crazy it was such a rush adrenaline it
was such a rush oh my God afterwards I
felt like I could seriously like hike
Kilimanjaro I was like this is
everything yeah that was fun so I get it
I would recommend to a friend yeah I
would do it again maybe like one day
I'll get into my cold plunge era
you have a house yeah I don't know if
anyone who lives in an apartment who has
a cold plunge well no they would just
like I guess go to their local gym and
the gym has a cold plunge like Equinox
probably does
oh I don't know right they would be
missing out if they didn't
I'm not sure
I don't know
so I like lived my frat girl fantasy I
had the best time the food had I mean
the food the party had the best food I
like never ate so much in my whole life
it was just a fabulous day being a part
of the 49ers family you know
um it looked fabulous I'm really happy
for you we missed you desperately I
missed you guys too but it was fun
following along and then on Sunday I
just drove out to Brian's house where I
stayed for a few days and had like a
real it was giving Canyon Ranch energy
you know
I woke up I played pickleball I
couldn't be more obsessed with
pickleball if I tried and I know it's
like oh Gladius like lasers are reading
I know I just want you to know in my
personal time I already added it to the
list
yeah okay whatever Claudia is like the
last stubborn [__] on this planet like
I know okay it's not even well that's
one thing but the other thing is like I
feel like you trust me and I'm always
trying to tell you like good things and
you just never take my word for it until
you have to like go and find out for
yourself I just want to say that's not
true okay and as it pertains to
pickleball okay okay because we played
pickleball I've played once before yeah
when we all went away for the weekend
and the place we were saying like had a
pickleball court we had the best time it
was like sisters split up I forget whose
team I was on but like it was just like
the four of us having we were giggling
cackling sweating like it was amazing
and I knew that I like liked it but I I
where the [__] am I gonna play
Pickleball like you okay okay privileged
Queen like you have a pickleball in your
neighborhood like how nice for you some
of us live in bunkers in New York okay
where the [__] am I gonna play
Pickleball okay just so you know they
opened like a million biblical ball
Courts for the summer in Central Park I
don't know if you saw those pictures
um because I was now that I'm so
obsessed and I've made pickleball my
entire personality because I'm
moderately good at it I I'm starting a
league I have to figure out who's
invited to my league and where we're
gonna get drinks after but I'm starting
a league that's a really great idea
yeah because like obviously I'm not you
know a super active person which isn't
like great for me I know that but it's
very difficult for me to even become
remotely motivated to get up like I'm
like exercises the bane of my existence
and I had so much fun I didn't it wasn't
even exercise but then I was like and
you know what I did hmm
it was so hot oh my God and I'm wearing
biker shorts and a t-shirt and a sports
bra and my t-shirt was just like
clinging to my back sweat so I took it
off and I was just like a girl in a
sports bra which is like not crazy
yeah I was like those girls who like sit
in the front row at Soul cycle you know
yeah who are just like aloe yoga set
active literally kissy face set active
I couldn't believe it I was like I'm I
put like a model whenever you do
something that's like
everybody does you kind of realize
that's why everybody does it like it's
nice not to have your T-shirt clinging
to you that was kind of the theme of the
weekend you know things are popular for
a reason I.E pickleball I.E sports bras
like I really that's like kind of
something I've learned in like later in
life like things are popular and like
well liked for a reason yeah like uh Ray
Dunn like the Stanley right like this
the Stanley exactly yeah no like I have
a Stanley and you know what she is that
[__] yeah she is I'm loving Stanley I
spent the weekend with Stanley it makes
total sense yeah
well I'm excited for you to come visit
me and we can play Pickleball yes oh no
by the way and the fact that I've come
to your house so many times and like
it's never even come up I know like you
and Olivia and the Zacks like over on
the weekends will like sometimes play
Pickleball that's how Zach Shapiro broke
his foot
um but like every time I've ever come to
your house and nobody's like let's play
Pickleball maybe I would have like yeah
but it's just like if we had suggested
it to you out of the blue you would have
been offended
yeah that's true because like when Dana
visited she was with me for like three
days we played pickleball every day
oh my God I'm obsessed like jaggy and
you're gonna be like so surprised I'm
amazing no that's the fun thing about
pickleball not to diminish you because
if you're saying you're amazing I
believe you're amazing and I'm pretty
good too no you don't have to believe me
like everyone was talking about it
everyone who's staying at Brian's being
like did you see Claudia she's so good
but the fun thing about pickleball is
that it's easy to be good and like good
enough to play and enjoy it because like
when you play tennis and you stink and
you miss every ball like that's not fun
but like if you play Pickleball for five
minutes you could pick you can get you
can hit balls back and like you can get
in the game and it's really easy to to
like carry a game
you know and it's not like when you play
tennis and like one person stinks or
both of you stinks you can't even get
like a three rally going like you can't
even get the ball over the net more than
three times pickleball you're right like
entry level it's very simple yeah but
everyone has different rules
I play some Abridged rules that I was
sharing with you but then I was Googling
it and then there's like more rules and
I think you just have to like pickleball
is kind of more personal than comedy
yeah because Brian had this role that I
felt like wasn't real and it was like
felt like an attack on me what was it
okay
no I serve the ball the person returns
it okay when it then gets returned to me
I can't volley it it has to like bounce
twice on Bounce once on each side that
is true
that's such a toxic [__] rule I did
not like that rule I'm sorry
it was annoying but at least you're
allowed to sing
true
so that was I think my my weekend recap
I just like when we got when I got to
Brian's it was real like relaxed energy
been cooked like we had barbecue we had
like all the Fourth of July things I
swam Brian rode horses it was really
like I did like we went out for dinners
it was really like Canyon Ranch energy
and Theo
blast I'm so glad to hear it do you want
to know what I watched this weekend
which is gonna really surprise you
because I had never seen it
okay it's a movie it's a movie that you
actually talk about a lot and I don't
know if I've ever admitted when you've
talked about it that I haven't seen it
oh my God what is it sliding doors
ready
I've never seen it either
I just know the concept I know like the
the concept of the film and it kind of
has like a larger message about life it
does but what's so funny is whenever
okay this is kind of a spoiler but not
really because I need to say what you
always say that turn out not to be true
because you talk about the premise of
sliding doors how she made the train she
would have seen her boyfriend cheating
on her and then oh by the way I didn't
even know that her boyfriend cheats on
her I just know that either she gets on
the train or she doesn't oh no you this
is what you've said she makes the train
and she sees her boyfriend cheating on
her and so she goes on to like break up
with him you know girl boss live her
best life meet someone else whatever
there's a situation where she doesn't
make the train and she does in fact she
misses the cheating and she stays with
her boyfriend and they like you know get
married and
live together and she never knows and I
was like waiting for that to happen at
the end and that is not how it ends so
like the whole time it was actually nice
because I thought I knew how it ended
but I was very surprised by the ending
the ending was good but there was
conflicted messaging because I felt like
the whole time it was like you know one
instance could change your whole life
but at the end then the message really
was what's meant to be will be
interesting I have to say I've never
said anything about her boyfriend I
don't I don't even know that she had a
boyfriend in the movie like the only
thing I know about the film is that
there's two scenarios and they involve a
train like I don't know anything else
they invite they involve doors that are
sliding
precisely well you should watch it I
enjoyed it obviously like I had my
critiques
of the protagonist but in general it was
really good Gwyneth is everything and
he's a star it was it it posed some
interesting questions okay I can't
believe you've never seen it I literally
watched it like Zach and I were looking
for a movie and I was like oh Claudia's
always talking about this on the show
like let me do my due diligence and
watch it that's so me like I'm always
just talking out of my ass that's like
I'm making stuff up you actually should
watch it because you love Gwyneth and
you always you cite the movie Enough
I know but now I feel like it might
spoil the magic
yeah
you know yeah now I like know so much
about sliding doors right you're like
kind of Gwyneth Paltrow's number one fan
oh for sure well number two after you so
true so that was a fun watch it's fun to
turn on a movie it is fun to turn on and
I really was really trying to be like
intentional with my movie choice you
know it was like I want to see something
I've never seen before but I don't need
to see like Avatar agreed just like a
good movie period
period I went to Max that's where I
watched it because I'm slowly getting
logged out of every every streaming app
they are cracking down they're cracking
down and I'm like not in my home so
they're like this isn't your TV so like
Netflix is done with me already I
already took right I went on Netflix
vacation where I'm like Netflix I'm on
vacation they gave me a few weeks and
then they cut me off again they need a
bed rest option yeah no they need like a
a short-term Stay option like uh Prime
video I can't get into YouTube TV is
like my location they're not believing
me anymore it's really a mess so I can
only really watch Justin Hulu and Max
now we still have so much catching up to
do and before we do that I just
absolutely have to let everyone know
that today's episode is brought to you
by ZocDoc have you ever been on the hunt
for a new doctor and you ask literally
everyone you know for the recommendation
well you know a doctor who actually gets
you listens to you makes you feel super
super comfortable after weeks of
searching you finally find the one you
call their office and they have an
appointment available but then the
receptionist tells you that this perfect
doctor does not take your insurance wipe
your tears put away the ice cream and
head over to ZocDoc you can find and
book the Doctor Who is right for you and
who takes your insurance
so ZocDoc is the and I'll be all for
finding a doctor who is in your area who
specializes in what you need them to who
takes your insurance who has an
availability for you
um ZocDoc is a place to find and book
great doctors who have amazing reviews
with tons of availability within 24
hours
is a great asset to use if you've
recently moved or if you're having like
a new medical issue and you've ever had
to see this type of specialist it is a
free app where you can find amazing
doctors and book appointments online
we're talking about booking appointments
with thousands of top-rated patient
review doctors and Specialists you can
filter specifically for ones who take
your insurance or located near you and
treat almost any condition that you're
searching for they have verified reviews
from real patients not robots the
average wait time to see a doctor booked
on ZocDoc is between 24 and 48 hours you
can even score same-day appointments go
to zocdoc.com toast and download the
zopdoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today that ZocDoc
zocdoc.com toast zocdoc.com toast I know
ZocDoc was really helpful for Jackie
when she moved because she needed all
new doctors and whenever if you're
traveling and you just need to see
someone ZocDoc is the place for you
support for today's episode also comes
from honey love the reviews are in and
honey love came out on top for the best
wedding day shapewear with wedding
season upon us this is the ad you've
been waiting for whether you're a bride
a guest you're just looking for an
everyday fit Honey Love Is Your go-to
for all things shapewear they have a
revolutionized revolutionized
compression technology so you no longer
have to feel like you're suffocating
while wearing effective shapewear I have
to say that's kind of been my crossover
I've been wearing shapewear since I'm
literally nine years old and the amount
of pieces of shapewear I've thrown out
in like restaurants and wedding venues
because I'm just like so nauseous I
could vomit
I have honey love I have like four
different items from honey love I got
them years ago they age so well and I'm
so excited they're a sponsor now when
you're when it comes to shape where
honey loves best-selling superpower
short is the go-to it has targeted
compression technology that
distinguishes between areas where you
want more support and areas where you
need less compression their signature X
targets and sculpture midsection without
squeezing your natural curves it's
designed to work with your body not
against it
struggling to take off a piece of tight
shapewear with a bathroom line out the
door is the worst but the shapewear from
honey love has 100 cotton gusset so you
can skip the extra undies plus it has a
convenient opening in the panty area for
super easy bathroom access it doesn't
stop there they have more than just
sculpt wear they have incredibly
comfortable bras tanks leggings that
also offer everyday support Honey Love
is just as easy to put on as it is to
take off because shapewear shouldn't be
so hard so treat yourself to the best
shape around the market and save 20 off
at honeylove.com toast use our exclusive
link to get that 20 off that's
honeylove.com toast
clardial
what else did you watch this weekend I
caught up on Kardashians like I said I
would
I was actually two episodes behind
um and what else did I watch
what did I say I was going to catch up
on I did like remember I said I'm gonna
watch Kardashians and one more thing no
I don't remember this at all there's not
that much like topically on right now I
know but what I did watch to mixed
feelings was shrinking
oh yeah I told Jackie that she should
watch it what do you have to say and I I
like the premise I really like so many
of the cast members and then it becomes
clear after a few episodes that it's
becoming like sitcomy where it's like
this is the cast of characters it's not
a drama it's like you know funny things
that neighborly things that happen and
yes everyone is interconnected
um and I gave it a lot of episodes maybe
like seven until I realized like if
someone told me I can never watch a show
again like I would be perfectly fine
with that it there's something like a
little cringy about the writing the only
person who has great lines is Harrison
Ford everyone else is just like there's
something weird about it and everyone
was like so mean to that woman Liz who
literally like took care of it is a
queen who is a queen like Wayward after
her mom passed away and her dad was like
doing cocaine with hookers prostitutes
yeah and we're gonna be mad at Liz for
overstepping no I was gonna ask you like
your favorite character because mine is
100 Liz and Liz's marriage is the
funniest thing the funniest thing and
it's a really good marriage and her
husband was 100 right about like he's
retired now like
for 40 years like if you want your space
like you leave the house
100 I love Liz so like there were sticks
that I really liked but then there was
like overall like Jason Siegel just had
some like really bad lines and like
as a character he was just like
bothering me and I was like you know
what this isn't sparking Joy
you know what it's not sparking joy for
me like recommending stuff to you like I
like this stuff and then you always have
like a [__] negative no but like you
never say you have to watch a show you
would absolutely love it and if you ever
do say that I feel like I usually do
like it but you didn't say that maybe
you said it about like the other two
I did say it about the other two and you
didn't even like the other two you're
just you know you're in like you're a
haterade when it comes to TV yes but I
don't think I I think even if I watched
the show like a year ago or a year from
now like I just still don't think it
would be for me like I think honestly
the bar keeps getting lower and lower
and like the other two is a really good
premise and they have funny moments in
fact same with shrinking but like it's
just they don't land the plane all the
time I really like okay say what you
wanted I know I don't want to stop with
the other two I'm not gonna say it
because I know that you like it so much
but this is like and I'm going through
something right now because it just got
canceled right so I'm gonna I'm not
gonna rag on it and there was one other
show that I started
that I was like
no no thanks what was it I forget it was
it was a few weeks ago
why don't you start I guess working moms
I never finished
okay you're also wrong about that I was
like it's just not good enough
oh my God the bar is so hot maybe that
bar isn't on maybe the bar is so [__]
high for you no and that's why it's like
the bar is high when I'm watching you
know like scripted High Production shows
but so it's either has to be like that
or I want low bar selling Sunset is fine
except I I put the bar down too low and
I started something yesterday that I
don't think I'll be finishing selling
Beverly Hills no no I'm not that
desperate the demilio show season two
oh okay I watched season one and I
thought it was a very unique and you
know interesting insight into the lives
of these two incredibly interested girls
agreed I'd like to see someone when I
think back on it because I didn't really
know anything about them as people but
there's just this slow pace to it and
also the producers make it worse by
asking these like dumb questions in the
interviews like
Dixie's in the studio how does it feel
to make you see her in the studio and
then they give like long answers and
it's just like let the girls live and
we'll watch it play out there is an
interesting thing happening with the two
girls though because they they they're
like really close as sisters but they're
inevitably like in competition with each
other and it feels like everyone around
them is constantly pitting them against
each other and
um like Dixie was the the less famous
sister is the last famous sister and
like she chose to do music which I think
when she chose it people were like whoa
that's ambitious and she kind of just
like toiled away for a year and now
she's like a nice music career she did
Jingle Ball yep and Charlie is like she
took a break from dancing she took a
break from everything because like she
started to hate everything because
everything became work unless we not
forget she's 16 years old like she
doesn't need to be like working day in
and day out
and then she's like I'm kind of feeling
like I want to do music
we reported a few months ago that she
was coming out with a song
so how does Dixie feel about it so
honestly sounds like the show's amazing
right on the show Charlie's not telling
Dixie she's doing Studio sessions and
she's putting them in her calendar as
acting sessions just to see if she likes
it enough to even tell Charlie but it's
like one that's what makes it Shady
because really I think Dixie would
support whatever Charlie wants to do and
two like if they play their cards better
they could have been a Duo act called
the demilio sisters where they both
dance and sing and Charlie's like the
better dancer on stage but Dixie's the
better singer no that's very interesting
so now they're gonna try and carve out
like two solo music careers for two
girls who are essentially the same no
it's
very interesting and also the show is
just [__] because like the first
episode is about Dixie playing Jingle
Ball and she's so nervous because she's
never really played a show before so for
your first show to be 20 000 people who
aren't there just to see you like BTS is
performing it's very hard to be like a
smaller act playing at those types of
events and every time the girls are like
nervous about something or they're about
to do something big the the show like
puts up these tweets around them like
from the haters like Dixie has no talent
and we're just like that's so toxic
they're like watching her like breakdown
she literally is about to vomit and it's
like Dixie will never be Charlie who
will even go to see Dixie oh that's
terrible it's terrible that's like
really that's like manipulative and like
bullying yeah no it's so weird and it's
like of course there are always going to
be haters but like the girls currently
has 150 million followers like why do we
need to see these haters opinions of
them even though I do think it like
really affects how they see themselves
yes it does seem like in this season
they have a much better grasp on Fame
and their mental health than they did
last season but still like they're just
they're just so young
it's hard to watch
damn sounds good yeah it no it's an
interesting premise but that's what I
mean when I say like the producers are
kind of getting in the way of the show
like just let the show play out instead
of like they're in an interview like
asking these deep questions it's like
Charlie doesn't have an answer for that
just let the girl live right like let
her go play with her friends maybe I
will finish watching it
sounds like you're loving it I only
watched like two one and a half episodes
in Dixie and Noah are like they're not
broken up but they're not in agree but
in real in real life they are so this is
obviously old oh [__] well in the show
it's like they're both so busy that they
like don't have that much time for each
other and then like making time for each
other becomes work a little bit yeah
which I actually they broke up a while
ago so they're obviously this is the
road to the breakup
they are such a cute couple I know when
I remember on season one like really
liking him as a character he is like
Scott Disick energy no I like him so
much as a as a young man me too I think
is a real stand-up guy he seems like a
really nice guy and a good role model he
had like a very good head on his
shoulders yeah
I like him and he was kind of like a
steadying force for Dixie
right
is 1060 been with anyone else since not
that I know of I think maybe privately
but not publicly oh and then Charlie is
with
Landon Barker okay I forgot Shirley
Charlie like
[Laughter]
Charlie like runs with the Kardashian
crew now
on the one hand I'm happy for her but on
the other hand like she needs to be
slowing down like it's already too much
just because it's already like the fast
the fast life
oh my God so I wonder if like through
the Kardashians of like Charlie and
Addison are spending time together okay
and we have a story about Miss Addison's
return today right so I feel like right
when Addison and Courtney stopped
hanging out is when Charlie and Landon
started dating so there wasn't much
crossover but Addison has made the made
the great return what does that mean for
Charlie yeah but also Addison's like
returning in like the mom friend and
Charlie's like the kids girlfriend
that's true it's like Charlie's almost
like her stepmother-in-law's friend yeah
like the two girls like both being
around them really highlights how weird
the Courtney Addison relationship is
because like Addison's friend is friends
with her kid
yeah but there's always been like a
small age difference between Charlie and
Charlie that seems so big yeah that's
true
so that's what I've been up to watching
very exciting steps different weekends
but both exciting nonetheless totally
and now we're reunited and turdy's
birthday's coming up I know it's on
Monday what are we gonna do
we'll be like we're trying to plan
something but everyone in the family
hates me and like doesn't care about my
birthday so
we Nix that
do you want to do like a daytime thing
or a nighttime thing
I just I know I say this every year I'm
sure if I like literally listen to this
episode today from last year I'll say
the same thing like I don't want to be
bothered with it and then the day before
I'm gonna be like mad that nobody did
anything for me like I'm so toxic do you
want me to like plan a little something
but it would just probably be like a
family thing not like with friends and
stuff and sometimes you like want to be
with friends and like go crazy yeah
Ben like keeps asking me about it I'm
literally like shut up like what is it
about birthdays and also like I really
don't want to even talk about how old
I'm turning because like I will jump off
my roof I did not realize how old you
don't even start you're such a [__]
like seriously I didn't or it hadn't
like sunk in until I was like doing some
math recently
I know and it was surprising but it the
good news is like you'll always feel
young when you're hanging out with me
age like it's not something I'm afraid
of like I'm not afraid of turning 29
because I'm almost 30 like I don't
[__] care I'm just thinking a place
right now we're like I don't have kids
yet and like the older I get it's like
the less time I have biologically like I
just know that that's a fact but I'm
also like not ready and I just think
like oh 29 you know they say after 35
like I just like I'm running out of time
I really need to be 25 like I just
desperately need to be 25.
I understand
like being a woman sucks I understand
but I also know what's ahead for you so
I don't really feel sorry for you
like I don't even like like I'm
literally that's that line from I think
Little Women I'm 27 years old I have no
money no prospects like have you ever
even seen Little Women or is this little
one Tick Tock Edition it's a sound that
went viral on Tick Tock and I just I
know that feeling like just feeling like
under
what's the word I'm looking for like
not like ill-prepared like I just don't
feel 29 you know I don't have like the
life of a 29 year old you know I'm so
22. no and you don't have no prospects
it's just this one thing
I know and it's like it keeps me up at
night but like you have a wonderful
career you have a wonderful husband you
have a wonderful Theo wonderful family
no it's true it's true and like I
shouldn't be ungrateful but I just like
this Crossroads I'm at a Crossroads like
for real
I need Kim Cattrall to show up and kick
me out of her house like that is what
you need a hundred percent like a Stern
fist not enough people talk about how
Kim Cattrall is the mom in Britney
Spears's Crossroads and that's a perfect
casting they couldn't look more like
right or ice princess
I think that Kim could oh my God I thank
you so much thank you so much I started
watching Netflix's new show called
gorgeous because I wanted to support Kim
Cattrall okay okay Kim Cattrall had a
new show here's the concept and you know
the concept actually sounded up my alley
so it's about this like cute little kid
well he's not a little kid he's like
this maybe 18 or 19 year old guy he like
loves makeup he like sells makeup at the
makeup counter and he like wants to be
an influencer he's like always running
home and his mom's like girl get a job
and he's always like making videos and
stuff like in his room and he's at the
makeup counter one day it all happens in
the first episode and Kim catrell is
kind of like Anastasia Beverly Hills
she's like this former model and she has
like the biggest Makeup Company in the
world and she comes in to like check on
her displays and he ends up like doing
her Glam and Kim Cattrall loves him and
hires him and like it's the start it's
kind of like Ugly Betty like he's you
know not experienced but Kim Cattrall
sees something in him and he goes to
work at like her mega mega makeup Empire
okay
sounds great Jack Jackie
I
I was shocked
I could not believe
that Netflix had the absolute audacity
to put this show on
it was horrible like I was Jackie I was
in [__] Shock first of all and like I
know it's probably like a really big
deal for the actor the you know the main
the main guy like
seriously like acting is not for him it
was so bad I couldn't Ben comes in he
watches for 10 seconds he's like this
can't be real the whole episode is not
gonna SNL skit it's cringe the acting
and honestly Kim Cattrall I don't know
who the [__] is like guiding her like
this was this is a stain on her resume
like I don't like I there there are
truly no words like unless you have seen
five minutes of the show you know what
I'm talking about like
Jackie
I can't I literally can't even explain
have you watch you half I have to get
back into my Netflix account I'm like
this is Netflix who literally made like
that Martin Scorsese Jimmy Hoffa movie
like Europe too but yeah okay but like
I'm saying like you I
I
I I can't even properly explain this
show you have to see it to understand it
I'm watching it I feel like I'm
literally in an alternate universe I'm
like what the actual [__] is going on
like the writing is horrible the acting
is horrible it's literally and honestly
it just made me then like question and
think about like Kim Cattrall's recent
moves you know she kind of can't catch a
break she had that show where she played
um
the mega church leader and like that
shirt was actually pretty good filthy
rich but it got canceled it's like she
really can't catch a break and so I
think she's just getting desperate and
this is like a project that had like
Netflix attached to it so like sure but
like this like this and I'm a Kim
control like I will till the day I die I
like scan cam control it really made me
question things
I have to watch it sounds amazing sounds
like my kind of show no it's not called
gorgeous sorry it's called glamorous
okay it's not called garages no it's
called glamorous glamorous with Shirley
oh my God I am so glad I remembered to
talk about that I was in tears I I felt
like seriously someone was playing a
prank on me I'm like there's no way
Netflix is the biggest streaming service
in the entire world was okay to put this
out it is moronic
great well I think on that note we can
get into the store we gotta go we gotta
go Gotta Go because there's actually the
stories are storing in a big way
you want to do well the next thing sure
sure I thought you were gonna cut me off
but without further Ado whatever here
are the past five stories that you need
to know
and the past five stories that you need
to know are brought to you bye
let me build your bedroom deserves a
refresh and now is the perfect time to
elevate the most important room in your
home with thuma so thuma has some new
stuff coming out and it's kind of
shaking up the industry the dresser by
thuma it is handcrafted from
eco-friendly high quality upcycled wood
the dresser has a modern minimalist
design that elevates any space so you
know we love thuma we love their beds
Jackie has one in her house it's
gorgeous it's great but mostly we love
it because it is so easy to assemble and
now they have the dresser that is also
put together using the Timeless
technique of Japanese joinery the
drawers are spacious and Innovative they
come ready to Nest making assembly
simple and quick with no tools required
if you have ever set up a like a thing
that has a drawer with the little wheels
and the little thing like you know it is
truly it'll drive you mad the dresser
from thuma doesn't have any of that it
fits in every space you can simply add
or remove drawers if you need to make
changes the dresser's generous subset
tray top keeps valuable safely in place
while the soft closed drawers provide
quiet functionality to the bedroom suite
it's made for how you live so the
dresser by thuma is backed with a
lifetime warranty and it ships right to
your door thuma works with one tree
planted to plant one tree for every
dresser bed headboard and nightstand
that they sell the dresser and all of
thuma's bedroom Essentials are green
guard gold certified meaning they've met
some of the world's most intense
chemical emission standards the lower
the chemical emission the cleaner the
indoor air so create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but from home with the
dresser by thuma and now go to thuma.co
toast to receive free shipping in the
continental US that's thuma.com
toast t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash toast for
free shipping
I'm assuming I know our first story
um yeah our first story Adele I know I'm
kidding I'm kidding Excuse excuse me our
first story Kyle Richards and Mauricio
nemanski uh are shutting down wrongdoing
speculation amid split so this weekend
it came out that Kyle and Maurizio are
separating they then put out a shocking
statement that said in regards to the
news that came out about us today any
claims regarding us divorcing are untrue
however yes we have had a rough year the
most challenging one of our marriage but
we both love and respect each other
tremendously there has been no
wrongdoing on anyone's part although we
are in the public eye we ask to be able
to work through our issues privately
while it may be entertaining to
speculate please do not create false
stories to fit a further salacious
narrative thank you for the love and
support
so this was really interesting
um you know the I got a People
notification and I've been seeing like
tick tocks and stuff people like you
know they haven't seen them together
they were like comparing Instagram
captions Kyle's been like running around
with this country music star so
everyone's like what is the T what's
going on
um
then I got the notification and it was
July 3rd in the evening which is just
absolutely brilliant it's giving Erica
announcing her divorce on Election Day
like
it seemed like they were trying to bury
it
um and there's so many interesting
things coming out of this and then they
responded and basically were like we're
having trouble but we're not getting
divorced so then dumois had pictures of
them they're all in Aspen together
celebrating the fourth with the family
it's all very confusing now what I find
most interesting about this is probably
not what most people find interesting
and I'm honestly I'm not going down the
rabbit hole and I'm not speculating
about like you know this country music
singer like what it means like I don't
do that like I don't care
I find this so interesting because I
have to imagine they just wrapped
filming and I have to imagine this was
like spoken about because you know they
said they've had a really challenging
year
um and I can't remember a time in recent
memory where like what was going on in
the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
wasn't in page six before it before it
aired and obviously the common
denominator on that is Lisa Rinna yeah I
think we spoke about this a few weeks
ago and this is like such like there's
clearly something major going on in
Beverly Hills and it's Kyle's marriage
and if it's spoken about on the show I
feel like
the fact that we didn't know about this
is so crazy yeah I mean people were
putting pieces together just based on
like loose things like Instagram likes
yes Father's Day post captions this year
versus last year you know comments that
Mauricio was leaving and the vibe is
that like Mauricio was still acting like
nothing had changed he was leaving
Flames emojis leaving writing nice
birthday things and Kyle's content of
Mauricio has gone down in the last year
and I I wasn't giving any Credence to
these rumors before the one that like
Kyle Mauricio there was trouble in
Paradise and two that Kyle
um is always with this country singer
Morgan Wade
but then after the news came out I was
like you know what let me see what
everyone's been saying so there was like
a highlight on one of the like Bravo fan
pages that really like
I saw it too okay yeah so I was like you
know what I'm gonna watch it let me see
like if the if there's anything here
that really catalogs all the Instagram
stuff and also what I found more
interesting was like Kyle's sort of
shift in Persona like in the last year
and a half so she met Morgan like she
was just like a fan of her music she was
driving and I didn't even realize
Morgan's a country star her music is
like extremely good and she was driving
and she just like played her album and
like really resonated with it and then I
became friends and it's clear that they
spend a lot of time together but also
like Kyle has like an edgier Vibe now
that's what the Instagram was saying and
then they posted like a clip from The
Reunion where she had gotten three new
tattoos and at the time it didn't seem
like anything but she had like this one
tattoo that was a heart and she was like
it was a heart because it's a heart but
it means something to me and Morgan
actually has like the same heart tattoo
so there's clearly like I think a change
in Kyle
and I feel like that could and I'm not
saying like she's been like cheating on
Mauricio I have no idea about any of
that but I do feel like she's ex doing
new things and like expanding as a
person and that could be hard on a
marriage of 27 years when like you've
been
this per like someone that your husband
expects you to be and then you are just
like going through kind of like a
metamorphosis and it's not aligning with
like what he's you know been able to
come home from for 27 years so yeah I
feel like the statement that they are I
mean the report that they were separated
is obviously the truth but also the fact
that they're not divorcing and that it's
been a hard year but they're working on
things and like the story's not over yet
I feel like that's also true
yeah I am concerned because I feel like
Kyle has really gotten away in like the
last 15 years with like being a Mainstay
on her show while giving nothing like
she's very behind the scenes she doesn't
really bleed out she like you know she
had the thing in the beginning with Kim
and that was like I feel like she's like
you know what I contributed like I'm
just like backing up and she hasn't been
like uh I think behind the scenes she
like makes moves but she hasn't been
very like outright vulnerable on the
show in a really really long time and I
really hope that we get like a like I
hope she doesn't sweep this under the
rug because this report came out like
after filming wrapped like I I feel like
I could see a world in which she like
didn't talk about it the entire season
and then just you know comes right out
after they rap
I could see a world where there's like
Clues throughout the season
which like I hate just like tell us
yeah
but I feel like it will be a focus on
the show but
it's like if nothing happened
and it's just like if you know
it's just about like Kyle in a new era
then but I feel like the women would say
that they would be like it feels like
something's changed with you but there
also a lot of them are heard like real
true good friends they protect they
wouldn't just like put her on the spot
like that that's an annoying thing to
say like you seem different yeah like
vague like what do you mean yeah
I don't know I just want to say like I'm
a huge Kyle and Mauricio fan like I
think they have a really really good
strong marriage and I hope that they can
work through it even if they don't this
isn't like a failure you know I'm being
married for 30 years is amazing in
Hollywood in Hollywood especially like
you know they they're super wealthy but
they weren't always and like money
changes people but they're like really
strong and I feel like they have a
really good you know family unit and I'm
really rooting for them I really am I
love Mauricio I mean a lot you know now
everyone's spiraling they're like well
there's something going on with gerina
Mauricio like last year people like were
pulling footage you're like something's
going on and now everyone's like maybe
there is something going on no I don't
think there's something going on I don't
think so either but they definitely like
really like each other not like in a
loving way but like in like a friend's
way they're cute together I'm obsessed
foreign
like that's and also it really seems
like
Mauricio like based on the social media
Behavior like Mauricio hasn't changed
how he's acting like I don't think
Mauricio did something wrong or it was
Mauricio's Choice like I really feel
like this is a Kyle initiative and maybe
that's just because of like what has
been presented to us and like people
don't we don't know what goes on with
Maurizio and what he does you know after
hours but that's just like what I'm
feeling
and I think when everybody saw this
statement that they posted the first
thing that came to their mind was
Allison Dubois oh my God the way that
bothers me so much is it bad to you no
but I get why it bothers you because
like I think it's funny I think it's
like something cruel what 16 years ago
and now we're gonna say she was right
like
you could predict anything like that far
out and eventually something that you
say will land but like you didn't
predict anything like no but but I just
want to say just to play devil's
advocate here for one second what she
said was very specific husband will
never emotionally fulfill you I felt the
same thing because it's not like she
said split up because you know what in
Hollywood you know you say that 50 more
than 50 percent of the time you would be
right right and so if the theory we're
working with now is like Kyle's kind of
having this metamorphosis because she's
not emotionally fulfilled at home like I
don't know it might have been it might
have been like kind of spot on
no I like literally I hate that woman
like I will not give her any credit well
she has spoken she posted on Twitter
she's like I wish Kyle no ill will
because everyone was like what is
Allison Dubois saying right now yeah
and she's still you know she's standing
firm on what she said she's doubling
down well now would be the time right
right there's nothing like being proved
right 10 years later more than 10 years
later
I just like I just I really my main take
not take away but my main message here
is like I'm really rooting for these two
like truly and honestly yeah I love them
me too and I feel like most like couples
who separate
in their marriage you know regular
people you never hear about it you don't
know like because they're not famous you
don't hear so it's just like the fact
that they have to go through it like a
moral like kind of like waiting like and
what shall be you know while Kyle might
need to like short some things out
within herself
this is really good um promo though for
this upcoming season I think people were
questioning you know what is the show
going to be like without Rina because
you know she's kind of a necessary evil
in a sense
um but this is definitely you know
making me excited yeah well I'm always
if it gets covered early Hills because
it's just fun to watch in general yeah
even when it's bad it's just like a rich
ladies being rich and like they're
really rich yeah so it will be good
regardless
um I I really am hoping that
that there's a positive a happy ending
to this me too
I would also just absolutely love some
clarity yeah I think we'll get clarity
like I do
through the season and stuff like I
think we'll see whatever's happening
like it will be right written on the
walls
well I'm truly rooting for them
seriously yeah agreed
great are you ready for our next story
yeah Fourth of July bash was popping
this year oh yeah Michael rubin's Fourth
of July party
um all the stars were out but one crew
that oh I guess pregame together that
really was really fun to watch was Kim
Kardashian Kendall Jenner Lori Harvey
Haley Bieber LaLa Anthony and Justine
Skye all were like tick-tocking together
before the party he has this annual
white party and they weren't even like
the biggest names in the room which is
crazy no the party was like it's every
year it's like oh my God what's going on
and it really this year he really
manages to how to himself people are
like who is Michael Rubin he's uh he
started that Sports company Fanatics
he's just like a really really wealthy
well-connected guy people in sports
Hollywood everyone just loves him and he
throws this party at his like beautiful
house in the Hamptons every year and
every year it gets bigger and better in
terms of who shows up who performs
everyone always wears white and it's
really just
fabulous and exciting to see the content
it's not one of those parties where you
can't take pictures they've got like
videographers they've got drones
everybody's making tick tocks it's so
fun and it's so cool and I'm obsessed
with Lori Harvey and This Crew like I I
have I remember like hearing and seeing
that Lori Harvey has like recently
become friends with like you know this
young Hollywood Haley Kendall crew so
she's coming in on like the Haley
Kendall side
yeah she's been spotted out and hung out
a bunch of times with Haley and Kendall
and like that Crew Love and I think you
know Kim was hanging out with like her
younger sister and her friends which is
like giving you know snitch energy but
also with Lala so she wasn't like right
she brought yeah she brought a plus one
yeah
um I was obsessed I think
another thing everyone's talking about
from this party is like two other people
where we're literally wearing the same
thing that Kim was wearing which is so
not Kim so that so not Kim like I feel
like that's her worst nightmare like I
have she's like the Pinnacle I don't
even think it's her worst nightmare
because I don't even think she thought
it was something that could ever happen
to her possibility she doesn't get
things off the rack like things are made
for her like she was she shopping at
Forever 21. Nordstrom's I'm a shocked
and one of the people wearing something
similar to her is Kanye's like girly
whatever her name is ex-girly Bianca no
no no that channy yeah chancy Chansey
um which is just even you know no power
so bad like if I were Kim I would like
make those girls have to leave the party
I was keeping up with everything but I
have to say some of the best footage
like following Liz hide on and sorry Liz
Woods she got married Liz Woods on
Instagram she was like
could you she was on top of it what's
the word I'm looking for congregating
aggregating aggregating all the content
and really pointing out how like so much
of what we see on Kim on social media is
like you know curated by Kim it's edited
and filtered not in a shady way like I
everyone edits you know and she has like
her own flow and her own aesthetic but
there were so many photographers
videographers just taking pictures of
Kim like from the side from the left
from the front from the right and it was
just it was very different to see Kim
kind of in the natural elements yeah and
also just to see Kim like in the context
of a party like we are always just
seeing her like kind of solo shots or
like her own photographer or her friends
like or the family like always posing
her family that poses but
um no she was just like a girl at a
party it was it was really shocking to
see and she's also just like wearing a
Layman's dress like honestly it was
really shocking yeah honestly I'm gonna
go out on a limited I don't think the
party was very good for Ken like
like that was one of my takeaways like I
was like damn like I don't know it just
it kind of was giving civilian energy
extremely civilian even though it was
like this A-list multi-billion like
everyone in the room was a billionaire
like it was just giving pedestrian for
Kim I completely agree but there were
also rumors that you know Tom Brady was
there right right right I'm sure they
spoke 100
what did they speak about
Jay-Z was also there like one of the
things that keeps me up at night like is
the relationship between like Jay-Z
Kanye Kim and Beyonce I don't know if
Beyonce was there she was in she worked
that day okay she was there but she
didn't pull up with you know in that
Jeep Wrangler and that Jay-Z was driving
with Corey Gamble in the back obsessed
like literally
I aim to be Corey Gamble in another life
like I don't know where the [__] he came
from how he's friends with everybody but
he's like literally so well connected
and I think people really like him and
like want to have him around because
he's not like a Clinger on like I think
he's like very fun and hilarious and
like yeah sure and by Corey we'll go to
the party together like I was obsessed
yeah no I think people just really like
having him around because everybody has
him around whenever they have the chance
to I loved it I and another thing
everyone was talking about was that Alex
Earl was invited yes which is kind of
you know reaching a level like it's kind
of a like a Rite of Passage to like
really be an a-lister like you get
invited to this party and I loved that
for her I mean I said Alex Earl should
have been at the Met Gala like I stand
by that I know everyone was like you're
crazy I was I stand by that totally also
Dixie was there
Charlie and Dixie were there last year
too and I think what I surmised just
based on my internet Gatherings is that
Michael Rubin has like young daughters
who are obsessed you know right yeah
why Alex are always there
yeah but like Alex Earl doesn't her
audience isn't like young teenagers like
daughter did you see her in all the
pictures front and center so like she
seems like older she seems like an early
in early in yeah but I remember last
year like early girly
I remember last year seeing pictures
like Michael Rubin clearly like asked
Charlie and Dixie to come and like did a
whole photo shoot with like his
daughters and Charlie and Dixie like it
was like a meet and greet
um I didn't see that with Alex Earl this
year you know God well maybe she's like
playing a cooler now
she's like chilling yeah yeah
giving friend not fan energy yeah no I
love this is my favorite time of year I
love the footage from this party I love
to see who shows up what everyone's
wearing and this year really it was no
different he truly Michael congrats
yeah and I hope that maybe some new like
connect like romances I really feel like
Chloe should have been there that would
have been a great place for her to meet
someone a hundred percent because not
only is it celeb filled but it's also
just like businessman Beau failed it's
filled with like Rich Hampton socialites
businessmen of course celebrities but
also Rich civilians which is what Chloe
needs which is what Kim is which is why
Kim is yeah no seriously like
yeah okay but
looking at it from the other side I also
feel like it might be nice for Kim to
just have had like a normie night out
for sure
no like everything is always just so
extravagant looks like about her and I
feel like every time she has a party
it's like she's throwing it she's doing
everything like she just got to show up
to a party and a dress that she bought
at the mall drink some shots you know
listen to awesome music have awesome
Shooters and just soaking up each she
was just soaking up everyone's awesome
okay like I feel like she maybe actually
had a good time
yeah I guess we don't know her like on a
personal level so we don't know if
that's something she would be into or
not into you know yeah because she's not
someone who complains about the fact
that like she doesn't get attention no
like I get no privacy and I can't just
be normal ever right right it was a nice
switch up change of pace yeah and Justin
Bieber was there I feel like he's never
really out anymore he looked well yeah
he did I
I saw the those pictures I loved every
minute I just I love this party I love
this journey for everyone
agreed beautiful it was a fun stalk from
bed rest it really was like thank you
Michael for doing that yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is some more Kardashian news actually
yeah what's going on pregnant Kourtney
Kardashian is showing off her baby bump
in a pink bikini which is so cute
alongside Addison Ray so the girlies are
back together Courtney reunited with her
pal Addison for a poolside hang on
Monday with the two of them twinning in
bubblegum pink bikinis Courtney was
showing off her baby bump and her friend
being back in her life and it was just
glorious for both of those reasons like
one I miss Courtney and Madison I
personally stand the friendship and to
pregnant Court
yeah I just want to say like when I
first saw this photo pop on my feet it
took me like 45 seconds to put together
what was going on I kind of forgot
Courtney was pregnant and then I'm like
wait Addison like I it was a lot of
moving pieces until it all clicked in my
brain
um and this these two like the the
Friendship dissipating over the last
year is not something that like kept me
up at night like I I understood how
maybe these two could could have become
like Fast and Furious friends and then
just kind of fizzled I didn't think
there was like a big
fight or anything this isn't one of the
things that kept me up at night but I
was overjoyed to see the two girls again
me too like I feel like when Courtney
and Addison got together it was like
right before Courtney
got with Travis and so they were just
like hanging out a lot and then like
Courtney like prioritized a relationship
also Addison got in a relationship with
like one of Travis's like music friends
yeah and then like Addison like took off
around the world Courtney got married
and like was really just in wifey mode
and now Addison's been posting like
every day like whatever she's doing
she's kind of back yep she's back from
her Hiatus and I think that means that
calling up her old friends again I agree
nothing nefarious happened here
no nothing neparity has happened but I
was really loving the content I'm so
glad the girls are still friends
um I also can't believe like I I
remember them being friends like they
were remember Courtney was in Addison's
Netflix movie like that was crazy yeah
they were Fast and Furious
yeah well that's the thing I hope we can
Usher in that error again maybe Addison
will be like babysitting
love love love
that would be awesome and that's also so
funny about how they actually ended up
meeting was you know all of Courtney's
kids were like fans of Addison it's
giving Michael Rubin energy yeah
yeah I'm happy that these girlies are
back together
um hopefully you know we'll get some
more content maybe some more Malibu
Beach walks yeah and hopefully Addison
will get in another movie because she's
my favorite actress well she is in that
um
Thanksgiving movie
which I plan to see so many lots of
movies but it's not my genre I don't
like the cards spooky I actually don't
know if I'll see it even though
Addison's in it Tim Dylan's in it I know
and there was someone else too I was
like this movie was made for me but they
just don't know I don't watch Spooky is
it Eli Roth It's an Eli Roth movie yeah
let me look at the Jewish King right
like
I feel bad because it seems right up
your alley
Patrick Dempsey Milo Mannheim
okay okay
I don't think Milo Manheim is like
that's kind of is it yeah yeah Tim Dylan
Tim Dylan
um
so yeah
Addison's back I'm happy she needed some
time out of town like I think we forget
you know it was probably really hard for
her when her parents were like acting a
fool making so much drama like
embarrassing her and that was probably a
lot and she needed some time off and I
respect that especially because she just
Rose to fame so [__] fast like she's
so young she needed time to
stabilize a little bit I respect you too
especially watching the demilio show
obviously like everyone Compares Charlie
and Addison not even for their work but
just like I feel like for the way that
they've handled Fame and I feel like
Addison has just taken a different path
um yeah of slowing down and I I I think
it could really be to her benefit
because the way that the like Charlie
and Dixie like it's not
like so healthy all the time it's not so
healthy all the time yeah yeah are you
ready for our next story a little
romantic news is it a little romantic
news that's brought to you by the
farmer's dog it is
whether you have a few weeks old puppy
or a senior dog who's seen multiple
decades any dog person like us knows
that the most valuable thing in the
world is spending time with your pet and
the farmer's dog can keep them healthy
which gives you more quality years with
them the farmer's dog makes and delivers
fresh healthy dog food it's recommended
by vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from human grade ingredients
in safe clean kitchens it's the best
option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canned
crap it's just real food traditional dry
and wet dog food options are extremely
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and they are extremely difficult to
portion accurately and the farmer's dog
isn't just high quality higher quality
food they also send the food
pre-portioned specifically for your dog
it's based on their unique nutritional
needs and it makes it easy to help
maintain your dog's ideal weight which
is one of the biggest indicators of a
full healthy life so we all know we want
to take the best care of our stressed
Brethren and feeding your dog like
actual healthy fresh food is has so many
benefits Theo's been on the farmer's on
for a while you know his breath is
better his weight is more stabilized his
fur coat is even shinier than you
thought it could ever possibly be
there's just so many different health
benefits from healthier coats to skin
better digestion smaller better poops so
a healthy diet isn't just important for
humans if you want to get 50 off your
first box of the farmer's dog go to the
farmersdog.com toast that's 50 off your
first box at thefarmersdog.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by codery for the other baby in your
life how many times do you get up in the
middle of the night to change a baby's
diaper if you have a little one it's
probably been a while since you went a
full night without interruptions well
codery diapers are designed for better
sleep and they've given us at least one
to three extra hours of sleep per night
because parenting is stressful enough
and you're supposed to somehow do it all
effortlessly it's the small hacks that
are the biggest game changers and for
Jacks I know it's definitely a better
diaper and that's why she uses codery
cottery is the highest quality diaper
that is extremely soft and super
absorbent so it gets us both through the
night cotery diapers are designed to
minimize leaks blowouts and diaper rash
so you and your baby can enjoy more
comfortable dry interrupted sleep they
have up to 70 percent more liquid
capacity and they absorb up to four
times faster by moving liquids away from
the skin within 15 seconds keeping your
baby drier than the leading diaper
Brands I know you got a big old box of
cotery in your hallway I saw it tell me
about your experience codery is an
amazing diaper brand honestly I saw so
many ads for it like just like great
videos from moms testimonials from moms
themselves before I finally got on the
codery train because once you're trying
to get your kid to sleep through the
night it's like you need a diaper that's
gonna help you facilitate that no
blowouts no leaks no anything in like
codery it's like they say they are the
Rolls-Royce of diapers so I sleep so
good when Harry's sleeping in his code
reeks I'm like it's not going to be the
P that wakes him up you know it could be
something else baby Tings but not the
diaper issue so I love codery and it's
made it's made with great ingredients to
put on your kids tush I love it highly
recommend
it's time to use a better diaper and
right now codery is partnering with our
podcast to offer you 20 off your first
order plus free shipping at codery.com
promo code toast that's codery spelled
c-o-t-e-r-i-e.com promo code toast for
20 off your first order and free
shipping codery.com promo code toast
great
our next story is some romantic news
Logan Paul and Nina Agdal are engaged
after he popped the question with the
wrong size ring just after their one
year anniversary so Logan Paul proposed
to his model girlfriend Nina Agdal on
Sunday night in Lake Como Italy a fellow
hotel guest who witnessed The Proposal
told the Daily Mail that they shared an
emotional Embrace just moments after she
said yes
I really like these two together I
actually weirdly like really like Logan
Paul
um I know people are like he's whatever
I like him I think he's really smart and
do you like him just as much as you like
Jake Paul or do you have different
feelings about each of them I have
different feelings about each of them I
I don't Jake Paul is a nut I can't crack
like why did the FBI [__] raid his
house like we never found out yeah but
that keeps me up at night yeah I would
like to know but like maybe they were
just like Raiden
you know especially if nothing came of
it like
what the [__] yeah by the way I don't
dislike Jake Paul either I just happen
to like I follow Logan Paul on like most
social platforms I find him really
interesting and really smart especially
like his energy drink and then his WWE
career I feel like he's really done very
well for himself and he doesn't get like
a lot of credit because I think people
are just like referring to him as like a
YouTuber and like his past scandals or
whatever but he's incredibly smart
um he really kind of invented that like
influencer boxing culture and I just
think he's like a good businessman and I
enjoy following him and I enjoy his
content and he makes a lot of content
with Nina and I think they're really
cute I think they're so cute
they look alike too I don't know a lot
of the difference between Logan and Jake
Paul they're just the Paul Braden to me
okay that's why it's like I like a most
yeah but I think this is such a cute
couple so well matched and they clearly
are like seriously dated for a year
they're getting engaged and they look a
lot married and that's how you know like
a couple is destined to be together like
when they start looking alike and
they're good looking
yeah tall and blonde yeah
I'm here for it like I think it's a good
match I think when they first started
dating people were like this is random
how do they know each other but I think
it's I think
she provides a lot of value for him in
his life and like his public perception
and she provides a lot of value like he
she's like a full-blown influencer now
you know she was like more of a model
but now she like makes content and
everything like I think it's a good
match I'm really here for it and I'm
happy totally beneficial relationship
while also being a love match which is
so I feel like that's all you can really
ask for from like a celebrity
relationship
yeah he kind of looks like Alex pettifer
sort of I totally see that yeah I'm just
looking at all these pictures of them
right now
yeah that's that's actually a very good
call yeah and Alex pettifer is so Random
like literally how is he famous what has
he like done no and I feel like he has
like a terrible reputation and it's like
he's not famous enough for how bad his
reputation is no he's like I know his
name like he has name recognizability
like what the [__] has he been in ever
and like no I've seen him in so many of
my crappy movies that I love right but
like he was in that movie with Vanessa
Hudgens like Beauty and the Beast remake
do you remember that no oh my God he
like turns into a beast it's actually
Mary Kate Olsen who plays like the
little wench who turns him into a beast
it's kind of a classic
I don't know if it's called a classic
Endless Love snitch's favorite movie
Endless Love yeah Wild Child which is
actually my favorite movie and not a
piece of crap and so good and if you
haven't seen it you have to see it Emma
Roberts had her best yeah
um Magic Mike I guess he's in I think
he's like okay big part of part of that
and he's in Magic Mike XXL
I also think he like went through like a
few years where he was dating really
high profile women and like that's why
we know him who is he dating
I think he dated um Nicola Peltz
oh yeah I'm like fairly certain let me
just double check
Alex pettifer
Nicola pelz he was in the butler
oh but he was Thomas Westfall the butler
has such an interesting cast it was like
all these famous people playing
historical figures
and it's always fun like Robin Williams
played Dwight Eisenhower did you know
that
no I didn't know that and I don't know
if Alex pettifier Nicola Pelt stated I
might have made that up oh it's okay it
sounds right
yeah he dated I don't know he's just
like I mean I literally Google Alex
Peter for girlfriend and he's like a new
girlfriend like another beautiful woman
I like I can't even keep track but like
a random person
yeah
but like lots of beautiful women
he's handsome
yeah never forget that James Marsden
played JFK and Minka Kelly played Jackie
O
well James Marsden also played the great
corny Collins so that's not joking also
historically correct
James marzin like
he he's a very like underrated
slay like he just kills like he's an
amazing actor I do think that like
recently him being on jury duty is like
one of the greatest things that ever
happened to him because he's like he's
not like somebody who's always like
being spoken about in the Zeitgeist like
he's just like a really kind of
consistent good famous actor but he's at
like you know he's on his name on
everybody's lips these days because of
jury duty and I'm happy for him but like
as someone who's loved him even like
through the dark eras yeah you know when
the calls weren't coming in for James so
true like it just I have to share him
with the world now
I by the way I understand that feeling
like it's like I put in all the work
I've been here during the dark times and
like now everyone's on board but like
what about me where were you like after
Enchanted
right you know just words
but like if you ever question James
marsden's Talent which I don't know if
somebody would but if they were all they
have to do is Watch Hairspray no and
nobody questions his talent like they
couldn't
they couldn't question you know what
things are popular for a reason
exactly oh and he wasn't dead to me
he was excellent in that he actually he
played two different roles because he
played two identical twins he's so
versatile
what can't he do oh my God and he was in
the best movie ever sugar and spice
that's definitely where my love starts
from oh my god well I think everybody's
love for James Marsden really starts at
27 Dresses yeah honestly not for me me
neither I don't I don't like even
particularly love that movie wait who
was he in sugars the best [__] movie
the the girls they were pregnant
together I think his name was Jack and
he was like the supportive boyfriend who
was excited to be a dad Jack Bartlett
and he didn't know what sugar is doing
sugar and spice is the most I feel like
people don't even know what we're
talking about I know but like because it
was like a movie about cheerleaders that
came out around the same time as bring
it on and like obviously everyone was
watching bring it on but honorable
mention to Sugar and Spice they're like
cheerleaders who rob banks you guys have
to watch it if you never have
and they're robbing a bank because one
of them is pregnant and she doesn't know
what she's going to do so she needs
money honestly it's like the story of a
woman in crisis yeah and her friends
rallying around her women supporting
women yeah it's a beautiful movie yeah
that's where the love starts for me so
true
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
an hour and 20 minutes later I am Adele
calls out people throwing [__] on stage
at artists she said I [__] dare you
during a recent weekends with the Dell
show the pop singer cheekily called out
the disturbing trend of people throwing
objects at artists on stage she said
have you noticed how people are like
forgetting [__] show etiquette at the
moment people just throwing [__] on
stage have you seen them I [__] dare
you dare you to throw something at me
and I'll [__] kill you she joked no
that's literally how I felt when I saw
those videos yeah like the rage that I
felt and so and I'm not even an artist I
was just like trying if I was Bebe Rex
so like I would have lost my mind yeah
and I'm glad that Adele's putting it out
there like I'll [__] kill you yeah I
will say I have been to Adele's show and
because Adele is like a certain type of
artist and the show is in like this
really sort of like Regal Caesar's
Palace like it's partially you know
you're sitting for some of the show it's
not the exact type of show where I feel
like somebody would throw something if
maybe just like a flower on stage
um so I don't think this is like gonna
be an issue for Adele but she's like you
know a major figure in the music
industry and I'm glad she's speaking on
it yes and she's like more of a mature
audience like if now like putting
together some of the singers who were
attacked it's like BB Rex at Ava Max
Kelsey ballerini pink and it's like it's
just like a Rowdy or younger audience
whereas so I think but still it could
have I mean it happened at Dave
Chappelle Show yeah that's true with
also I think a common theme for the
people
um pink
Bebe rexha Kelsea ballerini they were
all performing outdoors and I think
people just like get [__] crazy
Outdoors oh that's an interesting Theory
maybe it's like the fresh air getting to
their head or something
maybe I don't know pinks was also like a
festival all day people are like
drinking all day no this is just
something that needs to be nipped in the
bud and like so I guess Ava Max was
slapped by a concert goer who ran on
stage during her show and she tweeted he
saw me so hard that he scratched the
inside of my eye he's never coming to a
show again like I'm sorry that's just
not a harsh enough punishment wait he's
ever going to a show again he should
never be able to leave his house again I
want an eye for an eye
agreed come here let me slap you scratch
this guy for a scratched eye love that
also Kelsey ballerini was struck
yeah Kelsea ballerini was struck and she
had posted um I feel like hers was a
little different because I don't think
somebody was like trying to hurt her
they were throwing a friendship bracelet
which is something you know they do at
Taylor Swift shows and now like a bunch
of other artists are doing it too
um I think the person like didn't mean
to hit her in the face like BB rexes was
mean-spirited Ava Max's was mean
spirited it was attack like Kelsey I
mean it's unequivocally wrong like stop
[__] throwing things but I don't
think the person was like an evil person
who did it like I think it was like a
genuine mistake but the lesson is
stopped throwing [__] like it's a fear
of her so she also was just like a
mentally shook thrown off by it it
wasn't even so much like the physical
pain it was just like the [__] being
shaken up but I don't know like you're
not Babe Ruth like you have a terrible
arm don't [__] throw [__] especially
if you can't aim 100 percent
but like this is a really bad Trend and
I feel like it's not going
it's not going away and like what
they're gonna put up glass barrier
barricades you want that oh my God
literally you want that like celebrities
performing in cages
it just must be so scary like now that
it's happening to so many different
people before any artist goes on stage
it's like something they have to think
about yeah and they're not gonna like
engage with the crowd as much
you know you're going to want to stand
back from the stage so yeah so it's just
ruining it's just ruining the fun for
everyone yeah but I just feel like you
people can't control we need harsher
punishments for the people who are doing
this because maybe it would stop yeah
harsher punishments for parole violators
for sure you literally sound like Sandra
Bullock and Miss Congeniality Jackie I
thought the same thing because like if
you just get like tweeted about it's not
a big deal like but you need harsher
punishment so that like people don't
feel like they want to do this because
the concert
public shame we need photos of them
being posted everywhere that really
happened with Bebe rexha because hers
was like really the worst
um but some people that guy's photos
some people want that notoriety
you know like the true mentally ill
right like they're like famous Fame
everyone's Gonna Know My Name
you're so right so I don't think that's
enough
Jill I just feel like I get to throw a
phone at you then
yeah like come backstage and you want to
throw something at me I get to throw it
right back at you actually I get to
choose someone who's gonna throw it I'm
not gonna throw it out it's all crazy
yeah Gronk but then they'll do it so
that they can meet Tom Brady
a [__]
[__]
oh my God it's a vicious cycle yeah I'm
telling you it really it really needs to
be thought through
damn
well it has to stop and I'm glad you
know major players like Adele are speak
everybody needs to get a [__] talking
to yeah
wow I feel like amazing that we find it
like that we talked about everything you
know it's all out there we mentioned it
all we've mentioned it all and we had a
lot of good laughs along the way and we
really did what was your favorite laugh
of the show
question mine was Kim as a civilian yeah
yeah yeah maybe that maybe that'll be
our title maybe but people are gonna
want like Kyle and mo maybe we do like a
title this is what we do on days where
we have so much news like Kyle and Moe
Kim party is like a civilian and
something else and more
and oh my God that's enticing they will
click on that teasing yeah we're such
teasers all right well tomorrow's
episode is Jackson Claude back in studio
uh in NYC video and audio hope you
enjoyed today's episode and thank you so
much for listening to the Joseph
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories daddy you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up also available
podcast
leave a five star review about our
beautiful standing and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
happy hump day and we'll see you
tomorrow love ya bye